last week the president threw down with
Democrat leaders over his signature
promise to build a wall if we don't get
what we want one way or the other
whether it's through you through a
military through anything you want to
call I will shut down the gun okay
absolutely and is around and we disagree
I am proud to shut down the government
for border security Chuck well naturally
open borders Democrats desperate to
replace you with new voters are digging
in against the president president Trump
should understand there are not the
votes for the wall in the house or the
Senate he is not going to get the wall
in any form
oh no shock there he's not thrilled
about it but what about the House GOP
surely in their waning days of power
they have their priorities straight so
they'll finally support the President's
agenda and the rule of law right
do you like elf I think elf is probably
my favorite is what it's one of her life
it's one of my favorite movies of all
time I love it's wonderful life i watch
it every Christmas it's a thing I do
it's a thing I make my kids do it's
black and white they think they're
pretty confused about that the only ones
confused the cold hard facts are this
many Republicans have no desire at all
to build the wall they don't want to
fund it and they don't want it or
anything else that actually matters to
the voters who elected them now while
they're still being paid to do the
people's work
I think they've clearly moved on to
merrymaking frivolity talking about old
family movies and family favorites well
the administration however is doing its
best to light a fire under Congress
we're gonna do whatever is necessary to
build a border wall to stop this ongoing
crisis of illegal immigration and that
means this is a very if it comes to it
absolutely but so what if they only have
a few legislative days left in the
majority as today's New York Times
reports the Republicans are not feeling
the urgency at all quote vanquished and
retiring members are sick and tired of
Washington and don't want to show up
anymore to vote many lawmakers relly
two cubicles as incoming members take
their offices have been skipping votes
in the weeks since the House Republicans
were swept from power in the midterm
elections and Republican leaders are
unsure whether they will ever return oh
really
that we as taxpayers should be unsure
whether they're ever going to receive
their last paychecks or maybe a chunk of
their fat pensions for that matter this
is a complete dereliction of duty when
we have an ongoing emergency on our
southern border they're worried about
working out of a cubicle but let's not
kid ourselves my friends the leadership
of both parties again never wanted to
fund the wall speaker Paul Ryan it's a
nice person but he was always against it
remember what he said back in October we
intend on having a full-fledged
discussion about how to complete this
mission of securing our border and we
will have a big fight about that and
we're gonna be looking at doing just
we'll figure out how to do it in
December oh my god a full fledged
discussion a fight well we've had
neither and as I predicted in October
it's all talk push it to right before
Christmas they'll do nothing now does
Ryan really think we're all that stupid
and anyway what's there to discuss
secure the border that's what we want
we have people pouring across our border
children dying from the trek because
adults that will they know that if they
have a child with them they're gonna be
processed and then they'll be released
into the country that's just the way it
works well the truth is Republican
leadership for the most part with few
exceptions again never wanted a wall
they just want the appearance of border
fortification you need cameras you need
electronic devices you need these um the
the aerial devices to be able to place
it in the mountainous areas you can't
build a wall over mountain so you need
cameras and you need drones up there's
deep thoughts you can't build a wall
over a mountain okay anyone and anytime
they start talking about sensors and
drones they're closer to the Shumer
position the
the Trump position this is why I
repeatedly urged the Republicans to
elect a new speaker back when Ryan
announced his retirement they needed a
strong leader who would help enact the
President's agenda not someone more
focused on his long goodbyes I remember
just being awestruck the first time I
walked down that center aisle that
feeling just never goes away
I still feel it when I walk onto the
floor each and every time since becoming
Speaker of the House which is not
something that we were used to in
Wisconsin I'm the only one who's done
that I appreciate the indulgence of the
people I work for who indulged the fact
that I had other responsibilities in
addition okay well that's sweet there's
a nice little farewell address but we
should have to indulge anyone working
for us Paul Ryan is a really kind person
and he's a nice man and he's smart and
he always called the taxpayers his
employers I like that so shouldn't we
expect and we the people expect our
employees to work through their last day
on the job if we're in charge we say
work right well given the lack of
initiative in the house and absolutely
no direction being given by leadership
you might wonder how the retiring
speaker is spending his time
well yes prepare to put on a pair of
fuzzy jammies and watch Paul Ryan the
series a few days after he was sworn
into office I needed to know what is it
that you want to do the first thing in
service tax reform our tax system is
punishing all those qualities that make
America great it was political suicide
it was good work it's what
which is the most members were really
uncomfortable
I remember the difficulty Paul was
having and making that decision we
mapped out a calendar and we saw very
quickly you can't lose a week we're
gonna run out time it's gonna push
everything back and you're gonna ride oh
that's good
fire up the popcorn maker kids come see
how Paul Ryan did it I love how they're
worrying about running out of time in
that little documentary that we're
running out of time well we are running
out of time for America now this is my
last week on terrestrial radio and I'm
watching a new podcast in January a lot
of you've already heard about it but my
listeners today had this to say about
the Republicans refusal to do what's
right at the border purposefully
incompetent maliciously incompetent
political opportunists infantile call
your Congressman people out there
listening call them tell them no matter
what the back our president and those
are the nice things they said well you
may have to call your Congressman but
there are reports that the Republicans
are considering a continuing resolution
scam where they would fund the
government until September with no real
money for the wall now the people in the
White House cannot allow this they
should not stand for this bring on the
shutdown for all the bluster and the
worry about a government shutdown we all
should realize one thing with the
exception of tax reform which frankly
could have been a lot better and VA
reform which was good needed the
government has essentially been shut
down shut down to the will of the
American people for two years
does that sound harsh well I'm telling
you the way it is not the way you want
it you want it to be the Republicans
were elected to Congress to move the
Trump agenda and in many cases they have
frustrated it that is a fact
they passed a massive defense spending
bill without any offsetting cuts so much
for spending caps they secured no asylum
reform they did not end chain migration
they failed to produce an infrastructure
bill and they blocked the president's
efforts to fully fund his signature
promised and the reason why many of them
got into office in the first place well
it was supposed to be to build the
border wall Republicans are spending
time in political capital this week on
criminal justice reform which I
generally support but this was not the
reason the American people turned out to
vote in 2016 it's also not an emergency
whereas the disaster at the border
really is so whether they're retiring or
returning in the new year Republicans
should stay focused in in session
through Christmas if necessary to get
this wall funded I know what you're
saying it'll never happen Laurel never
happened well guess what this is our
country this is what they promised to do
implicitly
when President Trump was elected and by
the way this goes for the White House as
well for the retirees the holidays will
be here soon enough and they're gonna
have plenty of time to join Paul Ryan
they can binge-watch things like it's a
wonderful life and even as our political
one our political life becomes anything
but and that's the angle